now in the process of needing to fill
our canvas tiles the method of drawing
is a little bit different than what we
were doing before previously we're
actually just taking a view wrecked and
actually filling the data in but now
what we need to do is actually take that
same logic which we've actually
refactored for you here and instead of
drawing it based upon the view wrecked
we need to modify it to render tiles
into the canvas tile boundaries that are
being passed into the function this
works that once each of your canvas
tiles have been created you can actually
pass it off to the Phil canvas tile
function giving it the newly created
canvas tile now the code that we've
provided here is essentially the same as
a previous draw code just refactored the
primary difference is that our fill
canvas tile code should now take a
canvas tile as a parameter and then draw
to that canvas tiles context using its
bounding information rather than our
primary canvas context